[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui nous sommes sur le site des
ouvrages camille claudel à palaiseau qui
est le site sur lequel le premier
tunnelier que la partie est la ligne 18
va démarrer donc dans deux mois
maintenant et l'objectif de cette
journée c'était de le présenter
aux partenaires locaux et de faire ce
qu'on appelle le baptême donc avec la
bouteille de champagne mutuelle pour
marquer le coup de ce démarrage du
creusement du tunnel sur la ville de
palaiseau non pas une science exacte le
creusement des tunnels la vitesse
moyenne sur laquelle on compte c'est de
12 à 15 mètres
par jour c'est vraiment des vitesses
moyennes il ya des jours le tunisie va
beaucoup plus vite et puis il ya des
moments où
ça se passe moins bien dans ce cas là il
va très lentement notamment quand il
rencontre un sol difficile il ya aussi
des périodes de maintenance programmés
puis c'est évidemment c'est de la
mécanique de précision de temps en temps
comme pour votre voiture il faut
l'arrêter pour faire la révision est
donc ça on le fait de manière programmée
pour éviter les zones géotechnique
difficile donc pour être sûr que le
tunnelier va s'arrêter en sécurité
pouvoir redémarrer dans de bonnes
conditions
pour l'instant le calendrier est tenu le
programme de travail et même un petit
peu en avance puisque on va démarrer le
creusement avec ce tunnelier
de novembre de sept années 2000
vingt-et-une le deuxième tunnelier lui
qui sera baptisé dans un mois démarre en
descendre donc on est tout à fait en
phase pour les mises en service de 2026
et 2027 qui sont le calendrier qui est
actuellement prévu sur la partie est de
la ville pour la partie ouest de la
ligne dans les yvelines donc le
calendrier prévoit toujours une mise en
service en 2030 et pour l'instant on est
aussi en phase sur nos préparatifs la
même si les travaux n'ont pas commencé
les études se poursuivent en vue de
tenir ce calendrier
le baptême du tunnelier ça va au delà de
l'événement symbolique c'est un moment
très très fort je les rappeler tout à
l'heure à la tribune d'abord pour les
équipes qui travaillent sur ce chantier
d'arrache-pied jeux d'eau d'hier avec un
engagement sans faille extrêmement
importante place peine la tradition du
baptême du tunnelier est important pour
que ces édiles de profession je veux
vraiment saluer mois l'ensemble des
personnes qui se sont mobilisées pour
arriver à ce moment là un moment qui
n'est qu'un début on commence à creuser
et on est parti pour la grande aventure
concrète de la ligne 18 ans au sein du
grand paris express
[Musique]